istanbul is turkey's biggest city and
main economic hub many large firms are
based here under erdogan's rule turkey
has been transformed from a country in
economic crisis to regional power
after he became prime minister in 2003
erdogan privatized large state-owned
companies including the oil and gas
industry ports and airports and
liberalized the labor market hundreds of
new companies were created turkey also
recovered surprisingly quickly from the
global financial crisis the turkish
economy has grown in recent years by an
average of five percent annually
but not everyone here is thrilled about
erdogan's victory
critics fear the new president could
exert greater influence than before on
the economy
and
on the central bank
erdogan's drive to cut interest rates
and weaken turkey's currency has
undermined the credibility of its
monetary authorities and it has also
deterred investors
and while the economy remains strong the
lira is falling for years turkey has
imported more goods than it exports and
has been piling up debt